Dario's not allowed to catch it and so
Markel folks
they rise at Wells Fargo South
is back on December 30th another guy
that does you clods has got rid of folks
gliding in and getting the layout
that's got to feel good very thin
whose son Elias sobah on the case we're
gonna push it
here's folks giving it up Elia Silva got
it
give me a system arch help folks in a
playoff push well that's who stood out
to me was the fact that no one was
pressuring him despite what they're
going through Robert Covington promptly
laces the three she's yet to lead in
this one
trailing by as many as nine as both
slips in Bart hasn't covered Club eat it
for three you can't count it and he'll
probably go to the line looking for the
four-point play miles knows basically as
a jump shooter that time showing you
some athleticism folks denied by lovelyz
talked a lot of assistant coaches not
just on the 60 staff but in the league
and they think this kid's gonna be just
fine Martel cokes
rather high degree of difficulty
[Applause]
Belinelli Creek spot for folks who lays
at home
well you thank you for that pulses all
the floors we began the port your son
Elias sobah
mismatched here at La Mary the table
take advantage of his 11:26 assists on
32 buckets for the Sixers and feed
denied on the play by 12 appealing his
way through either he's just kind of
both feet in the deep end they spot
Amelia so give the young man an assist
Oh Craig fan nowadays
[Applause]
ready it's for three yes
[Applause]
ball sports in the issues promptly
rejected got it back charge for three
potent bald sports in the issues
promptly rejected got it back charge for
a three bolts hand the rookie knows pull
it back out
sighs that clock we run the big man
lovely shades free and get spell here
you go George in now rub his team
Tubbington for three
Michaelangelo the president's full
operation followed with a news
conference
drills the jumper and don't they love
particular flag and more trips remember
him in London as a matter of fact his
old family came to that London game shot